zu wenig impfstoff teils lehre
impfzentren und besserung ist nicht in
sicht der streit zwischen der eu und dem
pharmakonzern astrazeneca wird immer
heftiger
erinnerungen an millionen tote und
warnung vor neuen antisemitismus der
bundestag gedenkt der opfer des
nationalsozialismus und nur noch wenige
seemeilen bis zum ziel der deutsche
segler boris herrmann kann die regatta
rund um die welt noch gewinnen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten im zdf mit
norbert lehmann für den sport keine
genannter von mir
die impfkampagne gegen korona stockt es
fehlt an impfstoff doch wer ist schuld
an den engpässen hersteller astrazeneca
nennt produktionsprobleme außerdem habe
die eu zu spät bestellt
deshalb könne es länger dauern bis man
die gewünschte menge liefern kann
dieser darstellung widerspricht die
eu-kommission allerdings energisch
auslöser des streits die deutliche
kürzung der ersten impfstoff lieferung
nur 31 statt 80 millionen dosen bis ende
märz schon am montag hatte es
krisengespräche zwischen eu-vertretern
und astrazeneca gegeben eine plausible
erklärung blieb der pharmakonzern laut
eu aber schuldig in brüssel steht einen
verdacht im raum werden für die eu
bestimmte dosen an andere länder
geliefert
anne gellinek
es ist längst auch eine schlacht um die
öffentliche meinung eu-kommission gegen
pharmariese astrazeneca ein
krisentreffen für den abend wird
angesetzt wieder abgesagt und findet
doch in diesen minuten statt
die frage was ist mit dem von der eu
bestellten impfstoff des britisch
schwedischen konzerns passiert der chef
von astrazeneca hatte in mehreren
zeitungsinterviews bestritten dass es
überhaupt feste bestellungen der
europäer gegeben habe wir haben unseren
best fa zugesagt dass wir uns im besten
sinne bemühen
der grund war dass brüssel mehr oder
minder zum selben zeitpunkt beliefert
werden wollte wie die briten
obwohl die drei monate früher
unterzeichnet hatten
die eu-kommission keilt zurück im
vorvertrag mit dem unternehmen seien
liefermengen für jedes quartal
festgeschrieben davon dass die briten
zuerst zum zuge kämen sei nie die rede
gewesen
die sichtweise dass das unternehmen
nicht liefern muss weil wir eine best
effort vereinbarung unterschrieben haben
ist weder korrekt noch akzeptabel
der vertrag sieht einen lieferplan für
jedes quartal vor
astrazeneca erklärt den engpass mit
problemen in diesem belgischen werk die
eu-kommission kontert dass im vertrag
explizit auch zwei britische fabriken
für den eu bedarf aufgeführt sein aus
denen müsse der impfstoff nun auf dem
kontinent geliefert werden wer recht hat
kann nur ein blick in die verträge
klären
die aber sind bislang nicht öffentlich
ja in brüssel also gerade krisentreffen
zwischen eu und astrazeneca stefan
leifert wird nun geklärt wo der fehler
liegt zumindest ist das die kernfrage
dieses krisentreffen zwischen eu und
astrazeneca was jetzt seit einer halben
stunde ungefähr läuft und bei dieser
frage steht nach wie vor aussage gegen
aussage eigentlich wäre die frage
relativ leicht zu klären
dann nämlich wenn man die verträge
öffentlich macht das europaparlament
fordert dass die eu kommission will das
auch nur astrazeneca hat bisher noch
keine einwilligung dazu gegeben das
steht noch aus die zweite große frage um
die es geht bei diesem krisentreffen ist
die frage ob die eu kommission
astrazeneca nochmal ein zugeständnis ab
bringt die liefermenge an impfdosen für
das erste quartal doch noch mal zu
erhöhen zum beispiel durch lieferungen
aus britischen produktionsstätten diese
forderung wiederum erzürnt die regierung
in london
und spätestens an dieser stelle ist das
ganze nicht mehr nur noch ein streit
zwischen eu kommission und einem
unternehmen sondern ein politischer
streit zwischen eu und großbritannien
der so kurz nachdem rexit ziemlich
pikant ist keine der streitparteien
sieht heute besonders gut dabei aus vor
allem der eu kommission droht der impf
streit zu entgleiten und das obwohl der
impfstoff von astrazeneca ja noch nicht
mal zugelassen ist in der eu darüber
wird nämlich erst final am freitag
entschieden
zu den hintergründen des streits stefan
leifert vielen dank dafür nach brüssel
vor genau einem jahr ist die erste
corona infektionen in deutschland
bekannt geworden
seither wurden mehr als zwei millionen
fälle registriert heute meldet das
robert-koch-institut rund 13.200 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind knapp 2800 weniger als vergangenen
mittwoch hoch bleibt die zahl der
todesfälle 982 menschen sind in
verbindung mit coop 19 gestorben
166 weniger als vor einer woche
besonderen schutz brauchen ja die
menschen die in alten- und pflegeheim
wohnen oder arbeiten
da hilft nun auch die bundeswehr zum
beispiel bei den schnelltest allein
dafür stehen 10.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten bereit theoretisch in der
praxis sieht es allerdings anders aus
städte und kommunen haben nur wenige
angefordert wohl aus furcht vor den
kosten die aber würden übernommen sagt
die bundesregierung andreas neuser war
in fulda ein abstrich tupfer das
röhrchen mit der puffer flüssigkeit
natürlich eine uhr und das teststäbchen
was es für einen corona schnelltest
braucht hat die ärztin in wenigen worten
erklärt aber wie so ein test in der
praxis funktioniert müssen die soldaten
erst noch lernen für den echten einsatz
wir haben im landkreis 34 soldaten im
einsatz davon sind acht soldaten hier im
rahmen der schnelltests in der
pflegeeinrichtung eingesetzt und die
anderen soldaten im rahmen der
kontaktperson nachverfolgung aber auch
in den pflegeeinrichtungen ganz regulär
um dort als helfende hände zu
unterstützen
mehr als 15.000 soldaten hat die
bundeswehr für den kampf gegen korona im
einsatz der hotspot fulda nur einer von
vielen orten die um hilfe gebeten haben
wir reden regelmäßig mit den
einrichtungen wir haben eine größere die
sich vielleicht selbst besser helfen
können aber gerade kleinere auch in
ländlichen strukturen sind auf hilfe
angewiesen und insofern ist es ganz gut
dass die bundeswehr uns dabei
unterstützt ein bis zwei tage dauert die
ausbildung dann sind die soldaten fit
für die hilfe das ist unser job
wir haben dafür freiwillig gemeldet und
die aufgaben hierzu gehört bekommen die
irgendwie raus
im marienheim gehört es zu ihren
aufgaben personal und besucher zu testen
bisher war das aufgabe der pflegenden es
dauert 15 minuten bis der test
ausgelesen werden kann
bis die pflegefachkraft die
schutzkleidung angezogen hat wieder
ausgezogen hat das kostet eine menge
zeit die wir mitunter nicht haben weil
wir auch bei den mitarbeitern quarantäne
situationen haben wie lange der einsatz
dauert und ob noch mehr soldaten
gebraucht werden
der verlauf der pandemie wird es
entscheiden während der impfplan in der
eu stockt gibt es in israel keine
lieferengpässe das land in seine
bevölkerung im rekordtempo durch fast
jeder dritte hat inzwischen die erste
dosis verabreicht bekommen
in der gruppe der über 60 jährigen liegt
die quote schon bei über 80 prozent
spitzenwerte gibt es aber auch im
negativen täglich infizieren sich immer
noch rund 8000 menschen neu und auch die
zahl der todesopfer steigt weiter an
michael bewerunge berichtet täglich
meldet israel einen neuen imf rekord und
doch will die zahl der neuinfektionen
und kaum sinken die intensivstationen wm
hat das klinikum in jerusalem sind
überfüllt die behandlung von koma
patienten dauert einfach
wir versuchen die patienten auf die
region tel aviv zu verteilen oder auf
andere hospitäler die weniger
ausgelastet sind wenn wir zu 95 bis 100
belegt sind es ist wirklich schwer noch
mehr patienten aufzunehmen wirkt denn
die impfkampagne nicht professor worauf
macht die britische mutation
verantwortlich ihr anteil liegt in
israel bei 50 prozent
zwar wirke die impfung auch hier doch
die ansteckung bei den ungeimpften
verlaufe rasant es wird kommen die
impfung wird sich auswirken
wir müssen nur geduldig sein das problem
ist die ansteckungsrate ein patient kam
neulich mit dem flieger aus dubai und er
steckte 184 anderer 184 von nur einer
person
doch die geduld geht auch den israelis
aus weil das infektionsgeschehen so
dramatisch bleibt plant die regierungen
den lock down zu verlängern
netanjahus koalitionspartner benny gantz
will dem allerdings nur zustimmen wenn
die regeln strikt durchgesetzt werden
und die bußgelder erhöht werden
denn was nützt die schliessung der
landesgrenzen und des flughafens ben
gurion wenn viele ultraorthodoxe massiv
gegen korona regeln verstoßen
zuletzt reagierten manche auch noch mit
gewalt auf die kontrollen der polizei
dabei machen die orthodoxen bei nur 14
prozent bevölkerungsanteil 40 prozent
der infizierten aus diese sonderrolle
sorgt in israel zunehmend für kritik
corona und der konjunktureinbruch das
dominiert den jahresbericht von
wirtschaftsminister altmaier
darin schreibt die bundesregierung die
erwartungen herunter das
bruttoinlandsprodukt soll in diesem jahr
nur noch um drei prozent steigen
im september waren die experten noch von
4,4 prozent wachstum ausgegangen
schuld daran sei der neuerliche shutdown
florian hand mit dem ausblick auf das
wirtschaftsjahr 2021 berlins wohl
bekanntestes kaufhaus das kadewe am
mittag komplett verriegelt wie so viele
geschäfte logisch dass sich diese
maßnahmen auch in der grafik
widerspiegeln die peter altmaier heute
in die kameras hält der optimismus des
wirtschaftsministers etwas gedämpfter
als zuletzt
der aufschwung der seit oktober seit
september oktober zu beobachten ist geht
im jahre 2021 weiter allerdings mit
etwas weniger dynamik als wir gehofft
hatten
nach dem wirtschaftseinbruch 2020
rechnet er in diesem jahr mit einem
wachstum von drei prozent
erst mitte 22 werde die wirtschaft das
vorkrisenniveau erreichen
was dabei hilft dass ein großteil der
industrieproduktion derzeit anders als
im ersten shut down läuft was hingegen
nicht helfen würde so sagt die
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin veronika
grimm schnelle lockerungen in dem moment
wo jetzt noch locker würde und das
infektionsgeschehen wieder die heimische
währung würde auch diese unsicherheit
beim verbraucher denn bei den
verbrauchern ansteigen und das ist kein
umfeld in dem tatsächlich eine
wirtschaftliche entwicklung einer
erholung einsetzen kann
entscheidend sei daher dass
überbrückungshilfen auch ankommen von
den versprochenen november hilfen ist
aktuell gut die hälfte ausgezahlt
für mich ist unerklärlich dass es
blitzschnell ging bei milliarden zum
beispiel für die lufthansa und dass es
für manchen kleinunternehmer ewig
gedauert hat dass besteht die gefahr
dass weite teile des mittelstandes
hinweggefegt werden insbesondere der
dienstleistungssektor bricht ab altmaier
verspricht heute die noch offenen
anträge würden zügig abgerechnet eine
schnelle hilfe bietet der staat jetzt
galeria karstadt kaufhof der
angeschlagene warenhauskonzern bekommt
eine finanzspritze und zwar in form
eines darlehens über bis zu 460
millionen euro
erst ende september hatte das
unternehmen ein insolvenzverfahren
abgeschlossen
mit den geldern sollen arbeitsplätze
gesichert werden die hilfen sind an
umfangreiche auflagen geknüpft und jetzt
zur afg und zur frage einer möglichen
beobachtung durch den verfassungsschutz
vor dem kölner verwaltungsgericht
versucht die partei die einstufung als
verdachtsfall sowie die öffentliche
bekanntgabe darüber zu verhindern
heute hat das gericht vorläufig
entschieden dass einfache
parteimitglieder im einzelfall
nachrichtendienstlich überwacht werden
können abgeordnete dürfen allerdings
allein wegen ihrer parteizugehörigkeit
aktuell nicht beobachtet werden
das hat der verfassungsschutz zugesagt
so lange das verfahren dauert einen
wichtigen schlag gegen
computerkriminelle melden internationale
ermittler darunter das bundeskriminalamt
sie haben eines der gefährlichsten
werkzeuge von cyberbanden ausgeschaltet
die schadsoftware i want it server
wurden beschlagnahmt die infrastruktur
von imo tipp sei zerstört sagen die
ermittler
weltweit hatte hatte mit 2,5 milliarden
dollar schaden verursacht in frankfurt
am main etwa waren die server der stadt
infiziert und so teile der verwaltung
lahmgelegt worden
aber auch zehntausende privatleute
unternehmen und kliniken waren betroffen
monatelang demonstrierten in polen
frauen gegen eine neue verschärfung des
ohnehin schon weit reichenden
abtreibungsverbots vergeblich noch heute
abend will die regierung ein beinahe
vollständiges verbot in kraft setzen
bedeutet auch bei einer schweren
fehlbildung des fötus ist ein
schwangerschaftsabbruch künftig nicht
mehr erlaubt
natalie steger berichtet die ersten
demonstranten versammeln sich spontan
und frustriert vom polnischen
verfassungsgericht
das polnische abtreibungsgesetz
definitiv verschärft wird lange hatte
die regierung gezögert ein
entsprechendes urteil des gerichts im
gesetzblatt zu veröffentlichen
jetzt tut sie es tritt damit in kraft
ich protestiere gegen barbarei in polen
das ist ein skandal
das ist kein urteil und kein
verfassungsgericht trauer wut schmerz
mit misstrauen
ehrlich gesagt das polnische
verfassungsgericht auf
nationalkonservativer regierungslinie
hatte im oktober abtreibung im falle von
schwerster fehlbildung des fötus als
verfassungswidrig verboten
polen hat ohnehin eines der strengsten
abtreibungsgesetze europas schon jetzt
finden hier nur sehr wenige
schwangerschafts abbrüche stadt zur
verschärfung die regierung nur per
twitter
das urteil werde heute im gesetzblatt
veröffentlicht
damit müssen frauen also todgeweihte
kinder gebären nicht nur viele frauen
sind empört das ist skandalös und
beispiellos mit einem seriösen probleme
wie der abtreibung macht die
regierungspolitik das ist erst der
beginn der demonstration die letzten
proteste gingen bis tief in die nacht
es dürfte ein unruhiger abend werden in
turin und nun zu einem ganz anderen
thema das konzentrationslager auschwitz
wurde zum symbol des industriell
organisierten massenmordes heute von 76
jahren die befreiung durch soldaten der
sowjetarmee 1,1 millionen menschen waren
in auschwitz von den nationalsozialisten
umgebracht worden
ira hat heute der bundestag gedacht auch
mit aktuellen bezügen wie jürgen kehl
berichtet jüdisches leben in deutschland
76 jahre nach der befreiung von
auschwitz gedenkstunde im bundestag die
vergangenheit ist präsent aber vor allem
auch die verwerfungen unserer zeit
marina weisband die 33-jährige
publizistin kämpft gegen
rechtsextremismus das trauma der nazi
zeit prägen bis heute
familie hier den in deutschland zu sein
bedeutet vor allem zu verstehen dass es
passiert ist und folglich wieder
passieren kann
es bedeutet so verstehen dass
antisemitismus nicht da beginnt wo auf
eine synagoge geschossen wird das auch
die shoah nicht mit gaskammern begann
es beginnt mit verschwörung szene davor
warnt auch bundestagspräsident wolfgang
schäuble antisemitismus und
fremdenfeindlichkeit würden in
deutschland wieder offen gezeigt
jüdische mitbürger hätten angst manche
würden über auswanderung nachdenken das
beschämt uns es ist niederschmetternd
eingestehen zu müssen unsere
erinnerungskultur schützt nicht vor
einer dreisten umdeutung oder zucker
leugnung der geschichte als zeuge in
dieser zeit berichtete die präsidentin
der israelitischen kultusgemeinde
münchen charlotte knobloch als kleines
mädchen erlebt sie den schlimmsten tag
ihres lebens ihre großmutter wird ins kz
verschleppt großmutter sagt sie
ich habe weiß was das bedeutet bei einem
klammere ich mich an sie in liebe
zärtlichkeit geborgenheit
sie werden für lange zeit aus meinem
leben nach dem krieg bleibt die heute
88-jährige im land arbeitet für die idee
jüdischen leben in deutschland auf dauer
eine perspektive zu geben
und dann ihr appell ich stehe vor ihnen
als mutter grossmutter urgrossmutter
münchnerin bayerin deutsche europäerin
jeden als mensch ich bitte sie passen
sie auf unser land eindrucks vor der
veranstaltung
doch nun studieren arbeit und zum finale
der wohl härteste hochseeregatta der
welt der worte globe in 80 tagen um die
welt über 50.000 kilometer haben die
einhandseglerin und segler hinter sich
heute abend werden die ersten das ziel
erreichen in frankreich und der deutsche
boris herrmann der könnte sogar gewinnen
so sieht das buffet zur begrüßung aus
wenn alle restaurants geschlossen haben
die landgräfin boris herrmann bereitet
im moment gerade die anleger party vor
noch etwa sechs sieben stunden wird der
39-jährige unterwegs sein
hermann ist nicht nur der erste deutsche
der um die krone des hochsee segens
kämpft er könnte sie sich auch als
erster nicht franzose aufsetzen lassen
endlich der letzte tag
es ist ein herzschlagfinale in der
biskaya der deutsche wird wundert
dritter über die ziellinie segeln hat
aber eine sechsstündige zeitgutschrift
im gepäck die ihn wieder an die spitze
rücken könnte die auf dem wasser
führende activia kommt schon in der
nächsten stunde als erster ins ziel
es gibt bei charlie dallaire braucht
aber mehr als sechs stunden vorsprung um
dieses rennen um die welt tatsächlich zu
gewinnen
das bravo charlie im strandsand hat er
sich allerdings so oder so verdient in
knapp sechs monaten sollen sie eröffnet
werden die wegen corona um ein jahr
verschoben olympischen sommerspiele in
tokio das ioc allen voran präsident
thomas bach hat heute bekräftigt die
wettkämpfe sollen stattfinden
trotz weltweiter pandemie
80 prozent der bevölkerung japans wollen
die spiele nicht mehr rund 6000 corona
infizierte werden zurzeit im land
täglich registriert an olympia in tokio
will das ioc dennoch festhalten
wir spekulieren nicht darüber ob die
spiele stattfinden wir arbeiten daran
wie die spiele stattfinden werden
mehr als elf milliarden euro
investitionen stehen in tokio auf dem
spiel doch in den mittelpunkt rückt
zunehmend das in not geratene
gesundheitssystem in japan
wenn jetzt extra für die olympischen und
paralympischen spiele medizinisches
personal eingesetzt wurde gibt es mit
gewissheit stimmen die fragen ob das
abhalten der spiele wichtiger als die
gesundheit der bevölkerung ist in acht
wochen sollen die spiele mit dem
olympischen fackellauf eingeleitet
werden
und wir haben noch diese lottozahlen für
sie
die gewinnzahlen lauten 14 15 16 44 und
45 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
mit regen schnee und tauwetter ist
allerhand los morgen mehr zum wetter hat
gleich es denn terry
das war es von uns mehr gibt es im heute
journal mit bettina schausten um viertel
vor zehn
wir danken für ihr interesse wir
wünschen einen schönen abend und sind
morgen wieder da punkt 7 bis dahin
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine grenz
wetterlage bildet sich aus das bedeutet
aus dem nordwesten kommt kalte luft oder
aus dem südwesten milde luft und dort wo
sich diese luftmassen treffen da bildet
sich eine luftmassengrenze aus und die
bleibt für die nächsten tage bestehen
das bedeutet entlang dieser grenze gibt
es viel schnee nach süden regen und dazu
starkes tauwetter
denn es kommt relativ warme luft auf in
der nacht zieht regen und schnee
allmählich ostwärts vor dem südwesten
kommt neuer regen auf die mit glätte
müssen sie nach osten hin rechten
temperaturen im vogtland um minus drei
grad und 5 grad ganz im westen im süden
kommen größere regenmengen zusammen und
auch schmelzwasser also das wasser was
hier die berge abfließt ist in größeren
mengen vorhanden über der mitte dann
schnee und das bis in den nordwesten
ganz im norden entlang der küsten gibt
es sonnenschein und das bei temperaturen
von ein bis vier grad nach nordosten
senior dass es deutlich kühler als nach
südwesten
dort werden etwa bis 12 grad im
südwesten erreicht die nächsten tage
bleibt diese grenzwerte lage und zu
erhalten quer über deutschland vor allem
am freitag teils ergiebiger schneefall
bei null bis elf grad
damit ein schöner abend